طويله طويله جدا
هيا الرحله كانت
كلها مخاطر وكده
وضارب شديد حاصل
ضرب في الطريق
لما وصلنا مطار بورسودان شفنا طياراتنا
الحلوه هذه وجيشنا الحلو وكل التعب راح
للاسف معظم المعارك حاليا
بين المدنيين بالاحياء
فخطير خطير جدا بس ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله انه ما يروح لاكثر من هيك طريق من
الخرطوم لبورسودان تقريبا اخذت معنا
محدوده 38 ساعه بين الجبال وبين الشوارع
ونقط تفتيش وهذا يوقف وهذا يمشي وهذا يوقف
شوي وضع عطله الوضع الله يكون بالعون يعني
بساوي
حرب شوارع عرفت كيف
قتلى اموات في الشوارع ما في امان نهائيا
يعني عمليه التصويب ما بتكون على اشخاص
يعني الربع عشوائي على الناس حتى لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات